hi there today we'll be testing seven
different private browsers Brave epic
avar secure browser Komodo dragon
waterfox iron Libra wolf we'll be
comparing their interfaces and
capabilities as well as some interesting
settings we'll also test each browser to
see just how private they really are for
this test we'll need two different tools
the first is browserleaks.com which
offers a range of tests to evaluate the
security and privacy of your web browser
including geolocation and fingerprinting
the second is portmaster which checks to
see the kind of connections each browser
is making will not be considering tour
many people think that this is the best
and most private browser but this isn't
really true Tor browsers are used to get
around sensors and connect anonymously
to the dark Nets using onion routing
because of this the browser works very
slowly we've divided the video into
chapters and the time codes are in the
description so you can jump to whichever
browser you'd like to hear about this
video was created by the sum
subverification platform but more about
sums up in a bit let's start with brave
let's go to brave.com and download the
installer
the installer is launched and brave
downloads the missing components from
the internet at first launch Brave asks
to become our default browser and import
settings from our existing browsers
the brave interface looks a lot like
Chrome because it's built on chromium
therefore you won't spend much time
getting used to it Brave's source code
is open and can be downloaded from
GitHub this is important since you'll be
able to take a close look at the code to
see if there's anything dangerous now
let's see what this browser can do first
things first it asks if we'd like to
block cookies and related consent
notices which is good news for privacy
let's go to the settings by clicking the
button on the upper right corner and
choosing the settings menu here you can
set the look and feel of the browser and
adjust your privacy level in the shields
tab this is where you can disable
certain browser functions to protect
yourself from fingerprinting and
tracking such as Auto redirect tracking
URLs accelerated mobile Pages website
scripts and so on it redirects and
prevents your browser from being tracked
for commercial purposes below there's a
tab that lets you set your privacy level
when it comes to blocking trackers and
ads the standard setting is default
there's also an aggressive setting as
well well as a disabled setting this TSB
lets us disable all scripts and
fingerprinting and enable cookie
blocking so let's disable our scripts
and go with the aggressive setting if we
click on content filtering we'll get a
list of filters which Brave can use to
block ads and trackers let's click show
full list and we can see that just 10
filters are turned on by default we can
turn all of them on or only those that
we need but keep in mind that the more
filters you turn on the more content
that gets blocked which means you might
actually miss out on something useful
usually browsers store information about
the social media sites you're logged
into and share this information with
basically anyone to prevent this open
the social media blocking tab by default
it's set to allow Google Twitter
Facebook disable data sharing from
LinkedIn so if you want the HR
department of one of Elon musk's
companies to reach out to you consider
enabling this function here in the
search engine tab you can choose which
search engines are used with Brave by
default Google likes to know a lot about
its users and tracks their searches the
links they click on and the sites they
visit to stay safe you can opt for the
DuckDuckGo search engine so now let's
check what browser leak says about Brave
since all our scripts are turned off
including JavaScript it can only
determine our location and IP to a
limited extent but it cannot pinpoint it
also fingerprinting doesn't work
needless to say the internet without
JavaScript is pretty useless since most
websites use it therefore we're going to
turn on scripts for our convenience
which means that brave starts sharing
information about your device but in
such cases Brave has another great
feature which other private browsers
don't have let's click on the button in
the upper right corner and select the
new private window with Tor a new window
will open that's connected through the
Tor Network is this really tall yeah it
is now if we go to browser leaks it'll
show us that our IP has changed this
allows us to hide our location without
using a VPN however browser leaks has
determined that our new IP belongs to a
Tor node and certain sites prevent
access to tour users which you should
keep in mind great now let's see the
kinds of connections Brave makes when
surfing the web for this we'll use the
free portmaster program Brave regularly
communicates with brave.com refresh
servers and uses its own DNS service for
handling requests in addition to
whichever DNS servers are enabled in the
OS settings there are no other
suspicious signs in the requests sent by
Brave portmasters shows us that brave
users are built in 32-bit engine Tor
0.4.7.13 to navigate torn networks which
also works in a 64-bit system this is
the latest tool version this means that
it has all the latest updates and
features to offer a sufficient level of
protection So In Sum what can we say
about Brave it offers a high level of
privacy and works pretty quickly however
private windows with Tor takes longer to
load because the browser redirects
through the torn Network
Epic
let's check out the Epic browser by
hidden reflex an Indian company we'll
download it from the website and install
this browser is also based on chromium
but is non-open source which means that
nobody knows what's inside except for
epics developers epic does not have
built-in tour capabilities but it does
have something that its developers call
encrypted VPN in reality this is just a
regular old proxy which is built into
Opera it can change your IP address but
websites will still know your actual
location by default epic blocks cookies
and tracking preventing sites from
tracking sensitive browser parameters
and collecting data for ad purposes so
now let's hop on browserleaks.com to see
what the verdict is on Epic since
browser leagues can see our IP in
location we can see that JavaScript is
turned on by default if we click on the
umbrella shaped button to the right of
the search bar we can turn on the
Adblock and encrypted proxy modes by
default these are off we'll turn them on
an interesting feature of epic is that
it allows you to set website specific
privacy settings so just load a site
click the umbrella button and go to view
site settings so what do we see here we
can block the site from seeing our
location or whether our device has a
camera mic or other sensors we can turn
JavaScript image loading and ads on and
off this is really useful since
sometimes we need to enable these things
to get authenticated or use a website
properly okay we'll leave encrypted
proxy on turn off Geo positioning and
see what browser leaks can find
great we can see that our IP has changed
and browser leaks hasn't been able to
determine our location now we're in
Ashburn Virginia where we can visit
Ashburn Park do you think we're allowed
to feed the squirrels here
to change the main settings in Epic we
click on the button in the right side of
the instrument panel and head to
settings just like in Chrome all the
settings are laid out here just like
they are in Chrome for example if we
want to adjust our cookie settings clear
browsing history or adjust the personal
data that the browser shares with sites
on the web we can use the security and
privacy menu in the site settings menu
we can turn off geolocation for all
Sites at once now we'll use portmaster
to see the kind of connections that epic
establishes the browser actively uses
the Epic browser.com service domain
which belongs to its Developers if we
look at Wireshark we can see that epic
is sending certain data to developers
most likely the browser is collecting
some Telemetry to send to Hidden reflex
epic has one more interesting feature
which is pro mode as soon as you open
the browser the epic video downloader so
if you're a pirate or sorry a music and
video lover you can supposedly download
the content you want directly onto your
computer let's open the video downloader
and copy the URL
epic fail okay so maybe Google is doing
a good job protecting their content so
let's try the same on Vimeo
oh another epic fail
let's check our browser settings just in
case proxy is off JavaScript is on let's
try to download another video on YouTube
epic fail once again it goes without
saying that video downloaders can be
very useful but this one doesn't seem to
work on the most popular video hosting
Platforms in short epic protects you
from tracking and ads and its encrypted
proxy is useful for increasing privacy
however if you're a bit paranoid it's
non-open source code maybe cause for
worry
a vast secure browser Avast software is
known for its antivirus program Avast
this same company launched its own
browser in 2016. at first it was called
safe Zone and was part of avast's paid
antivirus program eventually this
browser could be downloaded separately
for free so let's download it and
install it
the installer is downloading the
browser's components and it seems like
it's trying to download half the
internet
the Avast browser is also built on
chromium and is non-open Source the
interface will be familiar to anyone who
uses Chrome however unlike Chrome the
Avast browser has a few extra buttons
this includes the Privacy guard which
allows you to prevent ads and tracking
on a given website the plugin extensions
button is the same as in regular Chrome
the security and privacy Center lets you
configure the browser's privacy settings
here you can toggle the Privacy guard
and the Web Shield which is a vast web
antivirus which protects users from fake
and or phishing sites you can also shut
off the password manager which saves all
logins and passwords in encrypted format
and lets you sign into different
websites with One Click by default the
Privacy guard is set to basic blocking
mode but we want some more privacy so
we'll click on the Privacy guard button
and head to the Privacy guard settings
we'll set it to strict blocking to
completely block fingerprinting tracking
ads and monitoring from social media
platforms oops the browser tells us that
the Avast team really needs to make some
money so they'll have to let certain ads
and tracking from their Partners slip by
so Avast is secure up until the moment
they can make a buck of your privacy
just a business nothing personal mate
the Avast browser has a protected VPN or
in other words the same kind of proxy
that's in Epic it's disabled by default
but let's try turning it on
oops this is a paid feature but they're
offering us a 30-day free trial should
we give it a try oops they're asking us
to add our bank card details or PayPal
info I thought we were talking about
privacy here okay let's move on to the
security and privacy center and open a
private tab now let's open browser
leagues in this tab overall there are no
surprises here the browser sends the
same amount of data that another would
with JavaScript turned on the IP address
is recognized and geolocation can be
blocked in a window that appears if we
look at traffic on the Avast secure
browser in portmaster we will see that
it interacts with the vast servers so it
looks like the browser is collecting
some stats in short the Avast secure
browser has the same functions as other
free private browsers but charges money
for some of them
Komodo dragon here's another browser
from an anti-virus provider this time
it's Komodo group this company makes
four versions of its browser Komodo
dragon which is based on Chrome in
either 32 or 64-bit versions and Ice
Komodo dragon which is based on Firefox
also in either 32 or 64-bit versions
let's download and install the 64-bit
Komodo Dragon browser which is also
based on chromium Komodo dragon uses its
own secure DNS servers which can be used
instead of the ones used by internet
providers during the installation
process you can choose how you use this
feature for instance by selecting
komodo's secure DNS servers for all
connections on your computer or just in
this browser only
the Komodo dragon interface looks a lot
like Chrome and the settings are
practically the same if you go to
websites using the https protocol the
browser performs an extra check of their
SSL certificates using an in-house
service and warns the user if they're
insufficiently reliable in addition
Komodo has an anti-virus program built
in which checks websites for malicious
code if we comodo in browser Lakes we'll
see that the browser blocks our precise
geolocation by default portmaster can
see that the browser communicates with
komodo's domains and AD guard servers
which have filters that are likely used
to block ads despite the fact the
browser is based on chromium komodo's
course code is non-open Source Komodo
dragon doesn't send any info to Google
servers however it does monitor user
behavior and sends it to its own
Services which is stated in its
licensing agreement the agreement also
states that users IP addresses are only
considered confidential information in
the state of California therefore the
browser maintains logs that track users
identified via cookie files or IP
addresses outside of California the
agreement also states that Komodo can
share data with Affiliated companies and
partners Komodo dragon blocks ads
tracking and offers built-in anti-virus
protection however it comes with a
non-open source code which was written
by a for-profit company so nobody truly
knows what's under the hood
[Music]
waterfox
unlike all the other browsers we've
tested waterfox isn't based on chromium
it's based on Firefox so this might be a
good option for someone who's used to
Firefox in the windows version this
browser comes with a 64-bit architecture
let's download and install it on the
surface this browser looks just like
Firefox with no significant ux
differences the settings window in
waterfox is exactly the same as Firefox
except for there being a look and feel
tab instead of a more from Mozilla tab
the most interesting tab for us is
privacy and security this one also
doesn't look different from what's on
Firefox with all the settings where
you'd expect them and there are no
unique settings or features when it
comes to privacy the source code for
waterfalls can be found on GitHub in
2019 waterfox was acquired by the Ad
Agency system 1. the project has 4 700
contributors which is quite a lot
however in 2011 this project was
developed by just one person Alex Kontos
it was 16 at the time browser leaks
Returns the same results for waterfox
that it did for regular Firefox notably
it recognizes this browser as Firefox
102.0 when the most up-to-date version
is 111.0
this shows that the version on which
waterfox is based is a bit outdated
which can come with some open
vulnerabilities the developers claim
that waterfalls can block trackers and
ads on websites but if you look at it on
portmaster we'll see that it makes
numerous connections with Google which
waterfox doesn't Block in full by
default only certain suspicious Google
Connections are blocked it's strange to
think that a browser owned by an ad
company would block ads right since
waterfox is based on Firefox you can add
any Mozilla plugins you like including
those which increase privacy block ads
or enable proxies but you can do all the
same in regular Firefox
iron this browser is from German firm Sr
Ware and is based on chromium for
Windows there are both 32 and 64-bit
versions the installer is analogous to
Google Chrome and the interface is
available in multiple languages besides
English iron looks just like Chrome
without any notable differences in the
interface the project was started in
2008 as an attempt to build an
alternative to Chrome that doesn't share
your Telemetry and other data with
Google the current version of iron also
has a built-in ad blocker a key
difference from chrome is that it
doesn't have the Google updater on the
one hand this saves on traffic and
resources on the other it means there
are no automated updates they need to be
downloaded and installed by hand iron
uses a secure DNS resolver its own
security DNS servers which filters ads
and dangerous content the browser
reveals users IP and location by default
in the settings panel there is an
anonymous VPN link which sends us to the
srware website but using this feature
isn't free after installing iron an iron
config and backup icon winds up on the
desktop to use these functions you need
to close all previously opened iron
windows so let's launch the configurator
the enable extended privacy flag blocks
certain requests made to websites for
instance content refreshes on the one
hand this prevents the transfer of
confidential information on the other
the websites may not work properly with
this function enabled the backup and
restore tabs allow us to save and
restore our browser settings if needed
the user agent tab allows you to change
how this browser appears to other sites
on the web for instance you can change
the user agent to Safari or several
other browsers Plus in just a click of a
button you can create an icon with a
user agent you set the import from
Chrome tab lets you import all your data
form values history password if you used
chrome before in portmaster Iron appears
as Chrome we can see that certain
websites send requests to analytics and
statistics servers but iron blocks them
overall this browser leaves a good
impression it works fast and uses secure
DNS to filter ads and tracking its
drawbacks include being non-open source
and having no built-in VPN since the
browser is built on chromium you can
download free plugins from the Chrome
web store including those that let you
use free proxies
Libra wolf labor wolf was built by
independent developers seeking to create
a version of Firefox that focuses on
privacy this is a relatively new
offering and has been growing in
popularity lately this browser is open
source and there's a link to the source
code on the Libra wolf website the
website also offers a 64-bit version for
windows with a standard installer and
portable app in a zip archive the
installation gave us no problems it went
just like downloading Firefox would to
those who use Firefox Libra wolf should
look familiar the first thing you'll
notice is that the browser uses
DuckDuckGo by default but you can change
this in the settings to go somewhere
else like CRX or Quant the browser
settings are overall the same as in
Firefox with no unique features if we
believe what librawolf.net says the
browser is designed to increase
protection against tracking and
fingerprinting techniques while also
including a few security improvements it
also blocks data collection and other
annoyances it also claims that it
doesn't collect Telemetry and uses a
u-block origin plugin to block ads and
filter content this same plugin works
with Firefox for safety Libra wolf
disables standard password managers but
you can use Firefox based plugins for
this instead the browser also enables
so-called enhanced tracking protection
which blocks side scripts that weren't
prevented by ublock origin since Libra
wolf uses enhanced security settings it
can interfere with authentication at
certain websites requiring repeat
sign-ins
to prevent this for instance to stay
logged into Facebook you'd need to add
the websites to your exceptions in the
settings browser leaks shows that this
website is safer than Firefox in part
due to the fact that webgl support is
turned off webgl is a JavaScript
interface for 3D Graphics which allows
certain websites to identify the
graphics card in your device the browser
disables exact geolocation and uses 11
content filters to block trackers and
ads it also uses canvas protection which
prevents fingerprinting by analyzing how
Graphics appear in the browser botmaster
shows that Libra wolf doesn't have any
suspicious connections there are
outgoing connections but they use the
u-block origin plugin to obtain content
filters and check digital website
certificates what's more the FAQs on the
developers website say that leverwolf
also makes an occasional connection to
check whether you have received push
notifications from websites you have
subscribed to overall we can say that
this browser left us with a positive
impression it has a familiar and easy to
use interface that works pretty quick
quickly
now it's time for our verdict in our
opinion Brave Takes the Cake it's open
source easy to use safe and has built-in
tour
Libra wolf comes second this one is also
open source and its capabilities can be
expanded with plugins this is a great
choice for anyone who's used to Firefox
epic and iron are tied for third place
these are commercial products that are
non-open Source however they're pretty
fast and have a lot of settings also
epic has a Content downloaded but it
doesn't work on YouTube the rest of the
private browsers we evaluated including
those built by antivirus software
developers will rank at the bottom this
doesn't mean that they're bad
necessarily however they're missing
certain useful features that the other
browsers have or they are charging for
features that the others don't charge
for
private browsers often have
functionality that will help detect any
kind of phishing attempts on your
personal information be it login
credentials or credit card information
interestingly though rarely does this
functionality cover any kind of
transactional fraud monitoring hi I'm
Lucas from sumsup and we are an
all-in-one verification solution that
secures every stage of the user life
cycle from beginning to end businesses
all over the world as you can probably
presume process thousands hundreds of
thousands of transactions sometimes
daily obviously within these
transactions there's a huge potential
for risky or fraudulent transactions
things of money laundering nature or any
kind of identity fraud that might be
going on with these transactions so it's
incredibly important to stay up to date
and monitor these transactions important
but not easy and the punishment for
missing these can be quite severe
whether through reputational damage
Financial or even closure of business
it's for this reason in fact that
businesses do take on third-party
providers to give them transaction
monitoring and security
some sub does provide this service too
and some sub solution is able to track
all kinds of suspicious activity send
out alerts react quickly to alerts have
our own rules generation ability and all
this in a very very simple user-friendly
non-code-based ux design to get started
businesses can either go with one of our
ready to use risk scenarios and
configure them to their liking or even
dig a little deeper into our rules-based
engines and come up with your own custom
rules from scratch using the sums up
interface the good thing here is that at
the end of the day you're going to be
provided with a thorough report on all
transactions and users which can be
shared with Auditors you can book a demo
by clicking a link in the description
that's all for now keep safe out there
in the online digital jungle and I hope
to see you soon
thank you